tenemos aquí dos de las derivadas más
útiles en cálculo sabemos que la
derivada con respecto a x del seno de x
es el coseno de x y que la derivada con
respecto a x del coseno de x es el menos
seno de x esta parte derivadas nos
ayudan a resolver derivadas mucho más
complicadas ahora bien lo que vamos a
hacer en este vídeo será profundizar más
vamos a demostrar esta primera derivada
en este vídeo no probaremos la segunda
pero podemos probarla usando la
información que utilizaremos en esta
demostración espero que esto te haga
sentir más seguro y que veas que estas
expresiones no son inventadas y que hay
un rigor matemático detrás así que vamos
a intentarlo la derivada con respecto a
x del seno de x bueno por definición es
el límite cuando delta de x tiende a 0
de el seno de x más delta de x - el seno
de x esto entre delta de x
simplemente es la pendiente de la recta
entre los puntos x
x y x + delta de x coman 0 de x + delta
de x entonces cómo podemos evaluar esta
expresión bueno podemos reescribir el
seno de x + delta de x usando las
identidades trigonométricas de la suma
de ángulos así que esto será lo mismo
que el límite cuando delta se extiende a
0 y ahora si si aplicamos la identidad
trigonométricas del pse nombre de una
suma de ángulos esto me va a quedar como
el coseno de x por el seno de delta de x
más el seno de x por el coseno de delta
tx esto es lo que sale del seno de una
suma de ángulos ya esto le quitamos el
seno de x y todo esto entre delta de x
lo único que hice fue usar las
identidades trigonométricas de la suma
de ángulos y esto a su vez se puede
describir como el límite cuando delta de
extiende a cero y déjame poner primero
esta parte de rojo del coseno de x por
el seno de delta tx entre delta de x y
tomaré todo lo demás en color anaranjado
observa que tengo la suma de varias
cosas y todo está dividido entre delta
de x entonces estoy separando las
fracciones más el seno de x por el
coseno de delta tx - el seno de x todo
esto entre delta de x recuerda estoy
tomando el límite de toda esta expresión
ahora el límite de una suma es lo mismo
que la suma de los límites entonces esto
será igual a el límite cuando delta de x
tiende a 0 del coseno dx que multiplica
al seno de delta de x entre delta de x
solo lo estoy escribiendo de esta forma
el límite cuánto delta de x tiende a
cero y veamos si puedo factorizar algo
por aquí tengo el seno de x que
multiplica al seno de delta de x menos 1
ok y todo esto entre delta de x y
revisemos si podemos simplificar esto un
poco más
en este primer límite observa que este
coseno de que es no tiene nada que ver
con el límite cuando delta se extiende a
0 entonces puedo sacarlos del límite
tengo jose de x que multiplican al
límite cuando delta de x tiende a cero
del seno de delta de x entre delta tx
ahora para este segundo límite primero
quiero describir al coseno de delta de x
a menos 1 como menos que multiplica a 1
- el coseno del delta de x y después
tengo este signo negativo por el seno de
x y por esta expresión y observa que
pasa lo mismo que en el primer sumando
el seno de x en este segundo sumando no
tiene nada que ver con este límite
cuando delta se extiende a 0 entonces
puedo sacarlo del límite y me quedan
menos seno de x que multiplican al
límite cuando delta de que extiende a 0
de 1 - el coseno de delta de x entre
delta de x
para finalizar recordemos que en otros
vídeos hemos demostrado que si usamos el
teorema de comparación obtenemos que el
límite cuando delta de que extiende a 0
del seno de delta de x entre delta de x
todo esto es igual a 1 y también en otro
vídeo usando la idea de que este límite
es igual a 1 demostramos que este otro
límite de aquí es igual a cero así que
te encargó que veas aquellos vídeos
donde demuestren estos dos límites ambos
límites son muy útiles en el cálculo y
usando esto simplemente nos quedaremos
con coseno de x por uno menos seno de x
por 0 por lo tanto sólo nos quedaremos
con el coseno de x y hemos acabado hasta
el siguiente vídeo